Luke Bryan bringing the heat to the
desert here at Stagecoach how you
feeling headlining yeah it's good I've
done I guess this is my third or fourth
headlining Adventure at Stagecoach so um
it's always fun being here
um just watching this Festival grow
through the years it's it's pretty
pretty amazing stuff not your first
energy like
life at that stage out there you you are
I mean everyone's waiting for you
well I just try to I just try to
always bring the energy up and have fun
and and I mean I've always
I've always been accused of not standing
in one spot so get out there run around
have fun interact with the fans uh and
just uh just make sure they have a great
time it's all about their experience I
mean they're the ones
that have traveled from all over to be
here and
um
I mean there's people like in tents and
campers and 100 degree weather in the
desert so um it's just the lead you know
it's my job to get up there and have fun
and make it a great experience for them
now the big question is will we get the
hips shaking the booty shaking up on
stage all of that there's there's always
a little of that uh but yeah you know
you gotta gotta gotta do that people
people buy a few tickets for that I was
joking with Riley green and Drake
Milligan earlier I was like are we gonna
see you front row in the pit when Luke
is up there are you gonna give him a
little run for his money and do a little
dancing and they're like nope we're
leaving that to Luke they said no one
moves their hips better than Luke Bryan
I almost steal some of Luke's dance
moves probably the hip shaking the booty
shaking got to yeah you know it was uh
it's kind of become one of my many
things
but uh but no it's fun just to you know
with me I just like to get up there get
in the moment and I feel like if I'm up
there
um dancing and shaking and being free
everybody else can too yeah speaking of
many things I know you have your
American Idol family with you here at
Stagecoach of course you know next week
we've got Katie and Lionel heading off
to the UK for the king's coronation do
you know who will fill in at idle for
them can you tease our guests it'll it's
it's big time it's big time but I cannot
tease but I think the viewers at home
will be really really
um
they'll they'll be they'll love to uh
I mean the people that we have filling
in I mean contestants have
have used their songs many many times so
that is a very that's a very broad a lot
more than mine any like any
anything more specific other than we've
used their songs you know I'm already
lucky to keep you know being a part of
the show you're not you're not getting
me kicked off Idols speaking of the
American Idol fam I wanted to ask you
Katy Perry and TR Thomas Rhett have a
duet now what do we have to do to get
you you know she's she's already hurt my
heart and uh broke my heart and uh that
sounds like a country song Maybe the
collab but uh yeah I mean I don't know I
mean Katie we spend enough time with
each other at American Idol uh but uh
yeah I mean I was I did give her a
little grief about
um you know the Thomas Thomas Rhett
collab but but you know he's a lot cuter
than me and I I get she she probably
followed her uh
she probably you know just went with the
cuter now I'm playing but uh but we uh
you know I I with with collabs and stuff
like that I'm always
um whatever works in the moment of the
song so um but you never know from your
lips to God's ears I'm gonna be keeping
my fingers crossed for that one
Luke Bryan always a pleasure thank you
so much
foreign